so where does the law come from we learn
in school the law comes from the
legislative branch of the government
when Congress passes a bill it becomes
law but this is only part of the story
most cases most court cases when they
when they're heard in front of a judge
or a straightforward application of
existing law but some cases are more
complicated than that some cases the
judge has to interpret the law when this
happens the judge writes an opinion a
text document saying this case we decide
the following for these reasons these
opinions are more than just opinions
these opinions these written documents
are actually law in the United States
and other common-law countries we follow
the principle of star a decisis but
started decisis means as courts are
bound by their decisions so in the
Supreme Court issues a ruling that
becomes the law of the land that is
actually new law with that Judge wrote
it also means do you have to rely on
precedent so when you're examining a
case you have to look back to what
previous courts have decided so in this
talk I'm going to talk about open data
networks specifically the networks of
cases and how they cite each other we're
going to talk about identifying
important cases in that network and
maybe at the end we'll talk about
community detection so if these opinions
are so important if they're law where
can you find them well if you go to a
law library at UNC for example or maybe
a large law firm you'll see these giant
rooms filled these large boring dusty
looking books they're called law
reporters when courts issue opinions
they're written up in law reporters
there's millions of them now if you're
thinking yourself this sounds a little
you know old-fashioned I can't apply a
regular expression to a physical book
well you're right there are digital
sources of legal data such as LexisNexis
or or Westlaw but none of them are free
large law firms you know pay for their
services and you know maybe one opinion
is 10 cents or something like that
but what if you want a lot of opinions
you know what if you're a public
defender or something like that what if
you're in networks
who's a grad student 10 cents times a
couple million documents is more than my
stipend it doesn't have to be this way
illegal data is not owned by anyone um
you know there's historical reasons why
what is this way well what about making
lead at legal data free accessible to
the public
enter the free Law Project the free Law
Project is a nonprofit that aims at
providing free public access to legal
data they have a website called court
listener where you can find a fairly
large amount of data so they have 3
million legal opinions and Counting
these opinions include the text data who
was the judge who wrote it when did the
opinion happen where was it etc etc they
have a database of judges almost every
judge and they have data about the
judges such as who appointed the judge
what are the judges political opinions
have they donated to any of the major
political parties they also have about
800,000 minutes of oral arguments these
are currently being transcribed by
Google's speech-to-text
API so Google is actually training its
speech recognition algorithm on court
Lister's data set and also court
listeners data set is becoming indexed
so people like you and me can examine it
now there's other sources of free legal
data such as Ravel and Google Scholar
that they're all great they all have
their pluses and minuses but we'll focus
on court listener today so court
listener makes bulk download of your
data easy one click to download 3
million court opinions so that's about a
30 gigabyte compressed file um I'll
confess I don't know how big it is
uncompressed because I tried to open it
on a shared Dropbox and may have crashed
my collaborators computers but it's you
know fairly sizable amount of data
importantly for us it includes the
citations so record opinions like
academic articles cite each other port
listener also offers a case
recommendation system called site-geist
so you know when you go on Netflix
Netflix says you might be interested in
watching narcos which you all should
watch it's kind of amazing um so you you
know doing keyword search some they do
some basic NLP um word Tyvek etc and
come up with a list of case isn't they
you know return the top 10 or top 20 and
so they have some they have some notion
of case quality um and right now that
notion of case quality is based on the
citations we'll come back to this so
what is the network well the great thing
about being in networks researchers ever
already knows what a network is
everyone's on Facebook so basically a
network is a set of nodes so people in a
social network and a set of edges a set
of connections UHN and ABI are friends
they're going to be different kinds of
networks networks can have metadata so
nodes can have values such as a name a
physical location edges can be directed
so if you're if you're looking at
academic papers academics and that one
paper will cite another paper that's a
directed edge some you might consider
that undirected but it's naturally
directed edges can also be undirected so
a being me and our friends that's an
undirected relationship edges can also
have weights now there's a lot of
networks that people are interested in
social networks is some of the most
famous Facebook and LinkedIn
neuroscience research is in neuroscience
so on the right we have a image of
someone's brain and what that is more
specifically is a diffusion tensor image
that is registered at the hundreds of
thousands long of long wispy white
matter fiber tracts connecting all the
neurons in your brain on the left and
network representation
I'm trying to learn something about so
the network we're interested in today is
the network of law case citations so for
example so are so in our network the
nodes are legal cases Brown versus Board
these cases cite each other remember by
stary decisis you have to rely on
precedent as much as you possibly can so
our edges are citations they're
naturally directed sometimes we'll
consider them to be directed sometimes
what we will consider them to be
undirected if you ever look at a network
data set um this is an important data
choice that you probably want to
consider both we have about three
million nodes in our networks through
the about approximately three million
cases on the court listener I'm in about
30 citations 30 million citations so
this is a fairly sizable network one
important feature of our network is
there's no cycles it's called a dag
directed acyclic graph so basically what
that means is the edges all go roughly
in the same direction
you can't cite a case that has not
happened yet case in 2000 can cite a
case in 1900 case in 1900 could not cite
a case in 2000 today we're actually
going to focus on us on a further sub
Network the SCOTUS sub Network SCOTUS
the Supreme Court of the United States
that has about 30,000 cases and 250,000
citations the citation is between two
cases from the Supreme Court so for our
analysis we did it in Python with
Jupiter notebooks on and there's a lot
of open source graphs networks package
by the way graphs and networks they're
interchangeable nodes vertices cases
interchangeable so we used to we use
Network X and I graph they're both
wonderful packages both open source
network ax is written in Python and is
really great documentation there's
example code you actually read the
documentation it's useful you know you
can find an example of what you want to
do copy paste change a few things and
you're good to go
I graph on the other hand is written in
C under the hood so it's a lot faster
for large networks and it's wrapped in
Python and R so you can use it if you
don't know C I don't know C
unfortunately there's poor documentation
for Python and this is not trivial
because it what it means is it takes a
long time to get started on there's good
documentation are just not in Python so
this is something we're working on
changing um but that matters so you know
when you're designing software patches
think about the user the the problem is
there really is an example code in
Python for for some reason it's like a
example code desert so what questions
are we gonna be interested in well I
think the first question everyone's
gonna think of is what is the
most cited case in legal history
basically what you're saying is can we
identify important cases from our
network what is important even mean can
we understand how legal precedent
evolves and can we help court Lister and
other websites build a better case
recommendation system so I'm going to
pass it off to Michael to tell you a
little bit about notions of important
cases so to determine which kotas cases
are born we'll be looking at the recent
top three centrality measures mainly in
degree closest centrality and PageRank
so visualizing large networks is pretty
hard um the first thing you want to do
when you get your data is you want to
look at it you want to visualize it but
we took on a default layout and I graph
to visualize our data using a physics
space heuristics approach and what we
got is a big ball of nodes and edges and
it just looks like a jumbled mess it
tries it's by using its algorithm to
place the nodes and edges is Oh as
beautifully as possible and we try other
heuristics layouts and they didn't
really do any better we kind of got the
same results so let's talk about in
degree and close to centrality in degree
of a site of a court case is basically
the number of citations that court case
gets and this is a pretty intuitive
centrality measure that most people
should do because it's the first thing
that's that'll come to your mind right
it's pretty easy and you're just seeing
if the most important court case is the
most static court case and close the
centrality is based on the notion of the
distance between two notes so the
shortest path oh so the distance between
two notes is essentially the shortest
path between two nodes so the distance
from Sam to Abby would be two and in a
directed graph you can only travel in
the direction of the edge so you're only
traveling in the direction of where the
arrow is pointing at so Sam
walk to Dan but then can't walk to Sam
in summary closest centrality measures
how close a vertex is to all other nodes
in the graph and closest centrality of V
is defined as 1 over the summation of
the shortest paths from V to all other
nodes so and in summary if the distance
of the shortest paths is small then the
closest sensuality is large but this
comes with a downside we have to compute
all pairs of shortest paths and we and
this actually is cubic in the algorithm
time and respect to the number of nodes
so we talked about using two different
packages to analyze our data network x
and i graph it took seven hours to do it
in network x but it actually only took
five minutes with I graph because it's
see under the hood it's a lot faster I
should say the developer time was also
reversed i graph it took five minutes
for me to write Network X sorry I'll do
i graph it took seven hours for me to
write I got Network guys you got network
X great documentation I graph uh we made
a get issue saying they need better
documentation so let's look at this
point pod example what is the most
important note according to degree
centrality B would be the most important
case it has five degrees and as the most
degree so it's getting cited the most
but according to closest centrality case
a is the most important case because
it's the closest to all other nodes in
the graph and it's an interesting
observation that a is between two
separate clusters of notes at the left
and at the right exactly so let's
measure SCOTUS by n degree so we have
this plot it's a visualization and this
network looks a lot different from the
one we saw before it's not a big ball of
nodes and edges and
I might actually be telling us something
so this is actually our SCOTUS Network
plotted where the nodes x-coordinates
are the court cases dates and the nose
y-coordinates are the court cases in
degree and we can already tell that one
of the court cases has a pretty high in
degrees getting cited a lot so let's
look at that this is the US vs. Detroit
timber and lumber company case it has
600 citations and it's about twice as
many citations as a second most cited
case so this is a pretty but this is a
pretty it's a pretty good case you might
think so initially but we found out that
is actually not an important case and
I'll explain to you why so law reporters
often write sometimes right cliff notes
are summaries about these court cases
and lawyers often cite these cliff notes
and summaries as opinions and by stary
decisis opinions or law what this means
is that the lawyers are essentially
using the cliff notes in the same way
that they would use opinions issued by
judges but cliff notes obviously aren't
law so Supreme Court recently ruled
against this practice so after this
Detroit case arm the court cases will
have a little syllabus written by the
law reporters and it'll have a little
footnote saying the law our reporters
are saying please don't use this
footnote as an opinion or as law see the
Detroit case and this kind of explains
why it has such a high end degree
because a court listener citation parser
accidentally picked up this footnote as
a citation so that's that's a data
quality issue that we actually fixed and
it's it's an example of a data quality
issue so let's measure score despite
closest and Choni now and before we
looked at in degree for a directed graph
right
you can't really look at the number of
citations of court case cuts in an
undirected graph but and foreclosing
centrality since it's um we're only
dealing with shortest paths we can look
at our directed version of SCOTUS and an
undirected version of SCOTUS so close
the centrality on the directed graph
when you look at this it doesn't really
tell us much because closest centrality
is a function of time right so it's
saying that the most important court
cases are the latest court cases we're
not really interested in that however
when we plot a closest centrality on the
undirected graph it looks a lot more
meaningful so we consulted on a law
student James Woodall and we listed the
top ten court cases by the highest
closest inchaallah T values and we found
out that most of them were procedural
cases so what are procedural cases well
procedural law is about how the courts
operate so it explains how our legal
system works and this means that two
different court cases from different
areas of law can cite a procedural law
because it explains our how our legal
system works so let's look at an example
this is Airy railroad versus Tompkins
and it explains about how the body of
law operates under federal courts and
this is a pretty important case because
this allowed federal courts to make law
about states and different jurisdictions
or about so if a state court if two
different state courts are handling some
case now federal courts cannot make a
decision about those two different
states so that explains how closest
centrality is between two separate to
separate clusters of notes no notes now
right because it's basically close to
all other notes because a bunch of court
cases from one area of law is going to
say this procedural law and a
bunch of poor cases from another cluster
of law is gonna say this procedure law
and I'll hand this off the into talk for
a patron thanks Michael so PageRank is
one of the most famous Network
algorithms it's actually what is
underlying Google search um
PageRank basically says you're important
if you're cited a lot and your insight
and your cited by other important cases
paetynn page and PageRank is actually
play on the words web page and Larry
Page Larry Page the founder of Google
should also mention court listener one
of the main people worked out in his
name is Mike listener so see a theme
there um so PageRank was originally
motivated for networks of web pages so
in this network the nodes are websites
and edges are directed hyperlinks
between websites so I post an article to
my Facebook and Facebook then links to
you know the New York Times or whatever
one thing to know is there can be loops
so my Facebook might have a link to my
LinkedIn which then might like to my
blog which might then link back to
Facebook it's remember in the citation
network that can't happen that's
important so what's the intuition behind
paytrik it's actually pretty simple I
imagine so randomly surfing the web at
the web in the following way go from
website to website to website by
clicking links when you're on our web
site that website is a link to a few
other web sites randomly pick one of
those links do that for a really long
time very occasionally very occasionally
pick a website totally at random doesn't
have to be connected to your current
website how long did you spend on
Facebook what proportion of that of the
time did you spend on a given website
that's it's valid that's the value of
its PageRank so for example the sum of
page ranks and a network sums to one
PageRank
it defines a you know a random walk and
it's a Markov chain and a finite state
space so we can write down a transition
matrix and use solve for the principal
eigenvector to compute the the
stationary distribution the upshot of
that is it's quick to compute pay track
it's just a couple of matrix operations
you know just think it was a couple
seconds on my computer both I Greta both
on i graph and network tax from 30,000
nodes so let's rank this Supreme Court
cases by PageRank and see what happens
well here the top 10 and you'll notice
that PageRank tended to pick older cases
so most of these cases are from the
1800s the cases that PageRank picked
were not necessarily themselves landmark
cases but they preceded landmark cases
so for example the slaughterhouse cases
they were the first cases to to chip
away at the 14th amendment so the 14th
amendment is the right to due process it
used when it was originally written
there is a very strict interpretation of
it so the slaughterhouse cases ever so
slightly expanded that interpretation
not of note but slightly started a trend
the slaughterhouse case by itself is not
important but it started this trend and
this trend led to the Civil Rights Act
the legalization of gay marriage so the
slaughterhouse case is not a landmark
case but it led to landmark cases so
that's interesting that PageRank picked
those here's a plot of PageRank values
versus time and you can see PageRank
tends to favor older cases it's not you
know it's not like stream um I would I'm
hesitant to use the word bias because I
don't really know what an unbiased
ranking would mean but know you could
say this is biased to to favor older
cases so here's the the Erie Railroad
case for example that was marked
important by on my closest centrality
was ranked 94th so PageRank said yeah
you know it's important it's important
remember there are thirty thousand nodes
but didn't rank it in top ten
so PageRank and closest centrality you
know they're getting at different things
here's the Detroit lumber case which
remember received a huge number of
citations it was not you know actually
that important well PageRank ranked at
65th so it didn't say it's irrelevant
but did it rank it in the top ten if you
remember that in degree plot that was a
huge outlier you know there's twice as
many citations as um as other cases
so in some sense PageRank is robust so
PageRank realized yeah
you know you've got a lot of citations
but you weren't cited by important
people so you know you're not so
important so that that's an interesting
future of PageRank that you always want
your algorithms to be robust so why does
the PageRank favor older cases there's
actually a pretty nice explanation of
that the problem or the reason is we
have a dag directed acyclic graphs
remember citations all go backwards in
time there can't be loops if you
remember how the the random walk works
it you know it tends to it follows the
direction of edges so maybe we started a
case in 2015 and then we jump down to
2010 then we jump down to 2000 and sure
you know it'll sometimes occasionally
jump all the way back up to to 2015 but
in general PageRank PageRank wants to
walk backwards in time so PageRank is
going to spend most of its time in older
cases the proportion of the time that
you spend in a case is its PageRank
therefore a PageRank in a directed
acyclic graph will prefer the older
cases so that's important to know if you
ever want to use PageRank on in a
network particularly directed acyclic
graph I'm sure this is known but I
couldn't really find this anywhere
online so there's other measures of a
vertex centrality
such as betweenness centrality which
basically says you're important if in
some sense you tend to be between other
cases betweenness centrality is similar
to closest centrality and it also picked
out similar cases it tended to favor
procedural cases so remember procedural
cases are sort of the ones linking the
many areas of law together couple more
algorithms the the hubs and authorities
algorithm in the eigenvector centrality
these are both similar to PageRank and
they basically say you're important if
you've got a lot of citations and you've
been cited by important people hubs and
authorities and eigenvector centrality
tended to favor substantive cases so you
know cases about a particular area of
law they actually both favored for First
Amendment cases I think eight and eight
of ten and ten of ten the top ten cases
from these two were on
we're First Amendment cases that's our
legal fibers found that pretty
interesting other legal researchers have
found that Authority scores actually
match well with that with sort of legal
expert opinion so that's always
something you want out if you're on out
of your rankings well it's something you
may want that it matches with what you
know the experts think um so this is a
plot of authority scores versus time um
and you'll notice that the authority
also did not pick the Detroit case as
one of its top ten you know it ranked it
on write it highly but again was
somewhat robust to that to the number of
citations so the Troy case was not cited
by important cases authorities did not
think that it was important that's a
great feature authority scores tended to
favor cases in the you know middle the
middle of the nineteenth middle of the
1900s so that's good I mean that's sort
of you know intuitively what you might
think leo where the in most important
cases would be so what have you learned
well every dog has its day there's not a
best measure of vertex centrality there
are different measures that get at
different things depending on your
context you might want to pick one or
the other so to court listener we're
recommending some improvements to their
recommendation system and this also
applies to other case recommendation
systems from other legal websites so
using other notions of vertex importance
in degree is a good is a good place to
start but there's other measures that
you might might consider probably
authority scores it's the one I would go
with actually a number of websites use
PageRank um which is we've seen as sort
of you know bias to favor older cases on
might be worth implementing multiple
recommendation systems or giving the the
user an option to say I want a
procedural case or I want a substantive
case um you sort of might be thinking to
yourselves well where's you know where's
time in all of this you know the a case
in nineteen twenty received a lot of
citations well maybe that case is not so
important in 2016
well doesn't show up anywhere and none
of the sort of standard measures of
vertex importance that you'll read about
in a network textbook explicitly get at
time
okay actually almost all of them will
sort of favor older cases just because
the longer you've been around the more
time you've had to be cited so that's
actually something we're we're actively
thinking about how do we sort of take
time into account and it's just probably
going to be some kind of statistical
modeling and as a stats PhD that makes
me very happy it's now I will talk a
little about community detection so
community detection is about identifying
clusters of nodes in a network its
clustering in a network so roughly a
community is a group of nodes that are
very densely connected to each other and
sparsely connected the rest of the graph
that's a heuristic statement there's you
know 400 different ways to make that
precise and but you know roughly that's
what it is so one of my collaborators
James Wilson applied community detection
to his Facebook um and I will say he
wrote down ahead of time what he was
expecting to find as a good statistician
would and he discovered seven
communities I think he had said he would
find six but they correspond did pretty
well to his Facebook friends to his
college friends described school friends
etc so you know here's a here's an
example that of course I selected where
community to action worked wonderfully
note that James also invented that
community detection algorithm Community
Action is unsupervised learning
so unsupervised learning is great on
some you know you can do wonderful
things with it you can find unexpected
things in your data but when you apply a
clustering algorithm you get clusters
there's clusters mean anything maybe
maybe not it's a you know million
different community detection algorithms
all with different motivations so you
know you have your classic optimization
based here's a here's a reasonable
objective function let's try to maximize
it oh well it's np-hard so let's put fly
some heuristics at it or maybe let's
write down as a Cisco model and apply
maximum likelihood estimation or for
Bayesian Xand I'm sure there's some do
people here you might do posterior
inference I'll confess I'm becoming a
Bayesian so what's gonna happen if we
apply community detection to our legal
network I've done this but it's
preliminary results so I won't share
anything with you but you might expect
to find court jurisdictions so there's
about 400 jurisdictions in
for 500 jurisdictions so the North
Carolina Supreme Court the North
Carolina state of Appeals the South
Carolina blah blah blah blah blah you
might expect that cases within
communities will cluster together so
that's you know what you would expect
but what about cases what about finding
unexpected communities that's sort of
what we would hope to find so for
example there's no good reason why one
jurisdiction should favor another so the
North Carroll there isn't a good reason
that North Carolina is Supreme Court
should favor the South Carolina Supreme
Court you know they're geographically
close to each other but legally that
doesn't mean anything but what if they
do that's that's interesting to know
that something community action might be
able to pick up on also community action
might be able to pick up sort of small
areas of the law so you know you can
imagine maybe there is 50 cases that are
all kind of about the same thing and
maybe they you know tend to set each
other maybe community detection can pick
that up can we just turn that on its
head and use that as a statistical model
for to understand how this network grows
that's sort of the direction we're going
right now
so to summarize open data is important
open data is important for everything
but open data is particularly important
for the law because legal opinions are
actual law if your axis is restrict is
restricted to legal opinions that in
some sense your access is actually
restricted to the law we believe in an
open judiciary in this country so that's
not a great thing if you don't have open
legal data then we can't do macro
analysis of the network you know sure I
can you know pick up a legal case and
read it but I can't analyze three
million legal cases without access to to
open legal data we learned about a
couple different notions of vertex
importance and I I imagine maybe some of
you have network data sets or will at
some point in your life have a network
data set it's worth considering them all
it's also worth considering your network
to be directed or undirected what is the
basic unit of your analysis this is
something we all face you know how do i
how do i look at my data well in
networks that's important and there's
data object choices directed undirected
do I consider my edges to be weighted
etc
and PageRank tends to favor older nodes
in a graph in a direct in a DAC so
that's important if you're applying to a
dag so just to summarize where we're
going right now you haven't heard me to
talk about much statistical modeling I
haven't fit any parameters which makes
me feel anxious as a statistician so
that's what we were doing now we're
writing down some models there's some
standard models for how a network grows
and you know they're all they're good
but weird we actually have a network
data set we have an evolving Network
data set so we can actually fit some
models to this um and that's sort of
what we're most interested in were sort
of we're also interested in combine we
haven't talked about the text data at
all we have three million text documents
that broke my friends computer well can
we combine that with the citation
information if we apply some kind of
document clustering like topic modeling
and you'll find all these topics so does
that correspond to the to the network
that we'll find from the earth side that
the clusters that we would find from a
network based community detection
algorithm what about combining those
thank you
I because the favored the older cases
have you looked at trying to predict
what recent cases will in the future be
what was the term Authority cases
authoritative case in authoritative
cases I noticed on the graph there was
one that looked very recent that was I
mean it wasn't very high up because it
was so recent but it was significantly
higher than the ones from the similar
timeframe and it looked like you know
twenty years from now that will be in
authoritative cases but have you looked
at trying to predict which ones you gave
a couple of examples of types of cases
that were that stood out as
authoritative were there any other any
other things like that yeah well so in
terms of sort of trying to predict
that's sort of I would you know that's
doing some statistical modeling so you
know when you're we fit a you know and
some model to our our network and we
might have a couple motivations one
might be to sort of understand what's
driving the growth of this network
another might be to try to actually
predict what's going to be cited um so
you know that's certainly something
we're looking at and so not yet but
that's you know we're in the process of
doing that the idea what the the recent
case that was slightly higher than the
Owens was you know I'm not sure which
case referring to but why don't we talk
about it after sure okay no got to
Mike's look at that I know it's a fringe
case but what about cases where there's
a appeal after a few years that would
change the assumption of directed cyclic
graphs right because at time t1 there
was a case and it was cited by many
cases but then t1 was repealed
so can they if the the new t2 case sides
back the cases and there is some new
evidence or new procedure set up then
the directed assumption will be changed
right and how would it change the
rankings if possible so the the
directors assumption would not change
that case because when a case comes that
you know it would when you won in two
cases you know that when you write an
opinion you you know you wrote down the
citations there so you can't you know
like go back in time and change that to
a future day you can't really cite
something that hasn't happened but you
did bring up an interesting issue you
know cases can be appealed they can be
revoked etc etc in some cases court
listener will sort of put squash those
cases together in some cases they'll
consider them as separate that's
something we have in you know taken into
account now but that's something we're
actively thinking about you know how do
we in some cases it makes sense to sort
of treat them as the same thing and in
other cases you know you should sort you
should treat them as different objects
but yeah that's we're we're looking into
that start back here this I wondered how
does the network based prediction work
when something has dramatically changed
in the law for example in one year the
government decides to remove the death
penalty and then how does the citation
network reflect the change that time
series problem yeah that's um so my my
advisor my advisers been sending me a
lot of papers on time point detection so
that's my advisors of propolis so we're
sort of thinking about probability
models for a time point two to four time
point change point detection sorry in a
network there's some work about that
that I am will be familiarizing myself
with um but yeah that's actually a
really interesting question that I
mentioned a network Reese researcher
named James Fowler and they sort of
looked at just the the raw site take
that the raw out degree of cases over
time so how many cases do I cite
and that's and what they found is before
the early 1900s
you mean maybe you cite one or two but
in the early 1900's - maybe 1930 there's
a giant jump in that graph that the out
degree and so what that says is people
started taking star a decisis seriously
in the early 1900s so that's something
that legal scholars had sort of you know
always thought oh you know roughly in
the nineteen and early 1900s people
started seriously considering started
decisis you know I need to rely on
precedent for my case to back it up and
they provided some empirical evidence
you know so I don't have the chart but
it's you know as you can imagine it's
just boom goes way up um that's just
very clear evidence you know that's and
that's a you know to change point in the
network yeah it's certainly an
interesting question that's probably a
you know PhD thesis right there maybe
will be my PhD thesis I don't know and
had a quick question is there would it
be worth attaching this data to
sociological data to see how divorced
court decisions are from what's going on
in society or whether they anticipate
what's going to happen in society or
they react to on yeah that sounds like
an interesting but hard thing to do
I mean I we have a lot we have all these
on you know these legal opinions that's
a lot of you know text data and I
imagine that you could try to tie that
in um yeah it's interesting thing you do
I mean this is a really interesting data
set and I mean it's you know there's so
there's a million different ways to that
you could attack it that are all you
know like genuine research questions for
legal scholars or for statisticians etc
so um yeah I mean I encourage you to
think about how you might do that I it's
still working okay so I'm just curious
if you looked at like so at least for
the supreme court it's considered
important by a lot of people that
they're independent of their politics
sort of so I'm just curious if you like
examined like anything about how like
the political
affiliation of the judges effects like
how they ruled on cases or anything like
that yes so that's why we're not looking
at that but there's a number of people
who have and actually currently are
looking at that so the the judge
database was compiled by I think a grad
student at Princeton and he's sort of
actually looking at sort of exactly that
you know Matt I'm looking at you know
how politics affects the way judge is
ruling I mean what you know when I
mentioned the judge database they they
took they they they put a lot of effort
into sort of putting the judges
political affiliations in there so that
data you know the data set is there or
you know growing to sort of actually get
at those questions so it is 12:10 I want
to go ahead and wrap us up maybe one
more round of applause